[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle cloud et safran et
je suis administratrice et la direction
de l'architecturé du patrimoine et des
jardins les administrateurs du sénat
exercer leurs fonctions dans deux types
de direction d'abord les directions
missions institutionnelles qui
correspondent aux missions classiques
d'élaboration de la loi de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et d'autre part
la direction dit ressources et moyens
qui correspondent à des fonctions
support ou logistique qui permettent aux
sénateurs et à leurs collaborateurs de
d'exercer leurs missions dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pour ma
part je suis en ressources et moyens
depuis 2015 d'abord j'ai été responsable
de la sécurité entre 2015 et 2019 et
depuis 2009 je suis responsable de la
division la maîtrise d'ouvragé au sein
de la direction architecture du
patrimoine et des jambes
[Musique]
les principales fonctions sont des
fonctions d'encadrement de toute
l'équipe de la division est par ailleurs
nous exerçons des fonctions de
planification de toutes les grandes
opérations en veillant en exécution à
respecter le planning et le budget
défini par le conseil de questure
l'année 2022 est une année qui a marqué
par des élections l'élection
présidentielle évidemment les élections
législatives ce qui induit une large
période pendant laquelle le parlement ne
travaillera pas en séance publique cela
nous permet à nous de faire des travaux
qui sont gênants et qui engendrent des
nuisances et que donc on ne pourrait pas
faire en temps normal sous peine de
mettre en cause le bon déroulement de la
séance publique en 2022 nous avons donc
un budget particulièrement conséquent de
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
grâce auquel nous allons pouvoir
entretenir le patrimoine qui est celui
du sénat dont celui des français
notamment en rénovant une salle de
réunion qui est la principale salle de
réunion du palais du luxembourg qui
accueille chaque année non seulement des
réunions internes mais surtout des
colloques ouvert au public nous allons
également engagé une opération de
rénovation des façades et des toitures
du palais nous allons rénover le local
qui accueille les membres de
gouvernements lorsqu'ils viennent
contribuer à la séance publique
ce qu'on ne dit pas assez de dégâts hier
au sénat c'est qu'elles permettent
d'exercer une grande diversité de postes
moi quand je suis arrivé j'avais 22 ans
j'ai commencé ma carrière en commission
comme beaucoup d'administrateurs et je
me serais pas douter qu'à 28 ans
j'exercerai dans un autre post les
fonctions de responsable de la sécurité
je suis arrivé quelques semaines avant
les attentats du 13 novembre 2015
ensuite il ya eu l'attentât du 14
juillet 2016 à nice et ces événements
aient un impact extrêmement clair sur le
dispositif de sécurité du sénat par
ailleurs j'ai aussi vécu un contexte
d'ordre public qui était lui aussi
délicat puisque la crise des gilet jaune
s'est produite pendant que j'étais
responsable de la sécurité bien sûr le
sénat c'est un une institution qui a
pour vocation principale de voter la loi
être contrôler l'action du gouvernement
et nous avons également tout un
patrimoine à gérer nous avons des
personnels encadrés et il ya énormément
de fonction qui finalement contribuer à
ce que les sénateurs travaillent de
manière sereine mais qui sont des
fonctions parallèle à l'élaboration de
la loi
[Musique]